Identification. This is Station fourteen recorded on Tuesday the sixteenth of September.
And of course the interview with faith and. And Karen and Craig and will begin in a few seconds and identification.
We were in at the end of last. Yes well. I did I finished off what I wanted to do in.
My father's village and those who were related to me and I came home. I was having coffee one day.
A young friend who worked on the bill picked. And I was just happened to be telling him that.
I'd finished the book and come home and finish the book and I had a copy of it and I showed it to him.
I was just excited the wonderful colors on Monk. And he said to me.
You know you said I'll talk to Bill about this you know we might be able to fit it into the series.
Well the result of was that was going back to Amber I'm. My father's village a television unit and to my father's.
We had a boy and of course the gay B.C. Arranged it so that we were and we were welcomed. Who was a Catholic.
There were seven Catholics and he absolutely insisted that we stay with him. And he lived in a quite.
In a place called Craig. The in the north. And.
You know I think the House must have been built by the first person when they're probably a planter. It had a very.
It had a lot. And we were treated the red carpet was out for us father who was just wonderful.
And he had a army of women who worked for nothing.
But that's how it was everywhere they have I'm not saying it was wrong but that was. At night we'd have.
We'd work all day from early in the morning.
Until about sunset and then we'd go back to the house
and there'd be a better half a dozen women there cooking the evening. And it was cooked as a French cook.
Because you see fathers it was French and we had chicken cooked beautifully.
The priest would go into his cellar and bring up the best of what.
And when the drink the ones that he would back down and bring up the French look at yours
and he'd say these are what the ladies of Paris. And this was true and I kept him supplied.
And I can always remember sitting out on the front for and there with Bill. And. I mean. We just sit.
He's smoking his cigar and me thinking about my dad. And all his family. And experience.
Yes it was a finish the job and they dropped the bill and myself and my brother wall off
but they aren't of Mahler cola. And they you know when to take some shots of the. Volcano. And very angry. You know.
And I went up and took some shots over the top of it and of course we were left on the island of mana color
and we said well how could you get it right anyhow my lookalike contacted villa
and they were simply a small plane over for us and the pilot said that he had to stay for a short time.
So we landed there and he had to pick up some something like that
and he was my brother was talking flight a happy camper me.
With the people of who understood that I didn't know that he could you see how does wonderful and to Terry my wife.
So finally we went back to the luxury of the first class hotel library. And I could scrape the dirt off.
Anyhow we did return and. The documentary wish shown on the A.B.C. In the series pictures Australia. Well.
I was going to say that I did talk about water Leni previously the person who became the prime minister of our two I
had a very high regard for water.
And he campaigned he was the leader of the campaign for independence over there
and the English guy even without any problem at all.
I think that had a lot to do with the fact that water happened to be an Anglican priest
and he had good communicating skills particularly with the English and with the church
but the French really dug their heels in. I didn't want to.
And I'm sure that if watered had a very good after independence to. Formed. A strong cabinet.
He would have done much more for the country than in fact he did
but the problem was then finding people with the skills and the know how. And it wasn't an easy task. Far from it.
It's a matter of fact and so course countries go around and the bloody hill now. Just got rid of water and.
Crooks came into it. Sad and terrible story. But that was found in my village. Well. I came home and. What.
Incidentally while we were sitting on that beautiful over and. The producer. I knew very very well said.
I knew he was going with a friend who intend to marry. And he said to me.
Well five we have decided to get married and we'd like you to marry us and want to have a license.
I can't marry you now. Lionel Murphy who had introduced the idea. You know.
Marriage celebrants and there were only about two or three marriage celebrant separate times there was Julia Morrow.
And Jill Fuller. And maybe one or two others. Now of course. But so he said to me.
Well I said I can't I haven't got a license. He said oh who fixed it and so when we got back to rank. And said to her.
You ring up Kep Enderby who was. The federal attorney and ask him if I can perform I'm married.
I don't know what happens. But the approval came through for me to perform the marriage.
I did the result of that without wanting to ever be a marriage celebrant I became a marriage celebrant.
Well that life as a marriage celebrant in the fifty's. And almost into the ninety's.
Was not without considerable interest. I refused to charge people last.
I thought you can make people pay to get married nor should you.
And I doubt some to cover my expenses if I had a fair way to travel or something like that.
You know I have always been for the belief that one should never have to pay to be buried. You know to be married.
Well. I was present and I go off and do a marriage and I come home and tell hands about it.
Why don't you write a book and call it WILL YOU MARRY ME. And I thought about this very seriously.
Remember I thought I'd end up in court.
Like for instance young couple said they liked me to perform the marriage so I said well you have to come and see me
and tell me what you'd likely to see him so focus on and I said.
Actually you can write it all yourself if you want to quite prepared to read it. But anyhow they came.
And asked to be married and I said well you will just be. And I said. Not having a breakfast.
Do you want me to perform. And park park which is right up on the Hill. Before you get into. Our city.
I said I'll just be asked to have couple of witnesses and couple of witnesses. So I would have to the pack.
And in the power in the group. And they witnesses and there was another couple there also who were sitting on a binge.
Just sort of looking out to the sea.
And when I called them together to perform the married couple came up and stood behind.
You know they looked like Pynchon. Really. Extremely poor.
And I thought the people in June in the park and they see something unusual. To just see what was going on.
Well after for saying goodbye to the couple. I said you had a couple of you know I'm looking.
And the woman and I were my parents. And then I stopped stopped and I said look it's been this way.
And the man who is Chinese. The parents a very American their daughter.
And that have opposed very very strongly very strongly. And she said I had to marry an Australian.
And he incidentally he was one of the owners of one of the restaurants damage Chinatown I might mention.
So you know there was. And then the Japanese woman and Australian man.
Who came and asked me to perform their marriage and I said years of course
when would you like to get married I said we'd like to get married on New Year's Day and she told me that her sister
and brother in law were flying in that morning. For arriving at six o'clock on a plane from Tokyo to be the witnesses.
I said you do you want to get married. Well out on the lookout amount of well every year.
Alan Ashbolt would have his party. And you know something like fifty of us. That he said to us that the previous week.
Not having a party this time you know so on. I thought that sort. We can get together another time.
But everybody went just the same.
And they could leave here first before they'd go around the corner to Alan's Fleiss so it got that way.
And we didn't get home till four in the morning and I had to be up there at six o'clock. I couldn't keep my eyes open.
I couldn't truly.
So I got out of there and had already resigned
but it still full of the background to the little marriage which just lovely. It was beautiful.
So then they say you must come and have breakfast I said I really should.
Oh you must come and have breakfast for the first break first.
We'll be at the bride's place in a second breakfast at the groom's place so we go up here to a unit with a proud list
and if we had you know. A teaspoon of fish and teaspoon or save.
And a teaspoon of something else and that was breakfast and it and a thimble of wine.
So then the next the broad group says Well now we're going to have my breakfast
and we went to his mother's place which wasn't awfully far away it was but he can and.
Toast and a big part of the well for years and.
They kept in touch with me and every Christmas the crowd would come from. It was a lovely absolutely lovely. Well.
You know that in itself is truly a book. You know the married. Of very very wealthy people. In the glory.
Backyard flick.
And you'd have one group and one in the garden and another group at the gathering not talking to each other
and what's going on right now. Or she hasn't left a will to this. Well no sense.
I didn't leave anything to that's what it was like when someone dies
and leaves the will lose all of the terrible up evil more often than not it's like this was married.
And here they were drinking while I'm not talking. And I thought Isn't it strange. It's a foreign culture to me.
And you did this for thirty years didn't show no I did it for for about ten years.
Yes it's about ten years since I stopped doing it but I only ever did three
or four in here I couldn't face it you know the squabbles between the relations and ring me up on that I'd say.
Look thrice.
I'm sorry that you have to perform this marriage of my son to that terrible woman she's a dreadful woman
or to be vice versa. Happens. She's marrying that man and that would be the room off.
And I would be the meat in the controversial. Yes.
Oh the WHO very very few that you could say were really happy with their problems family problems and.
You know they drink from Tasmania or Perth and. Get on a plane and come and marry us.
You know all expenses paid no worry.
And well the numbers of celebrants increased and it became quite commercialized and then I stopped.
I didn't tell anyone I was too ashamed to say that I was a celebrant became.
Because it became a manny making it and the fee was thirty five dollars per federal government
but a hundred thirty five getting away with it. And the very few times I did.
I'm sure that the wedding cake cost about three times as much as three. But there were people.
You know I can think of some marriages that were like. The one who worked at the time and he had his.
Marriage performed at the throw space place and. There was a lovely spirit there.
And I knew everyone so that made it really. But it seemed to me that the people life. Marriages I performed.
Were from the people from the doctors. And I did a little like a few weeks ago I was going for my poetry.
And I meet this bloke for an early morning. And we pass each other and come back.
He's picked his paper up coming back and he comes up in a front. Back garden.
Well the divorce came through and I swear. And there was a way to go over it. Believe in a bakery. With.
Ross Kelly was the witness for still a schoolteacher.
And I think the wedding breakfast came after they have a beautiful lovely. Well so much for being a wedding celebrant.
And then. During this time. I was. Neville ring ring ring me one day he said look I want you to.
Can you do the job and I said no problem really. He's very special.
And feels will be getting in touch with you all it's hard to say no to naval because of what he did for women in this.
Anyhow. Have a race.
Got a good committee going looking after the very disadvantaged given them and I thought you should sit on this board.
So you know I really want to get up in the morning again. I feel compelled. He says Oh now you can take it easy.
You have a driver. Well that was out of. People who are. So poverty stricken.
That they couldn't wait in the queue for a house. And my job was to assess.
Patients and the hapless cations were always prepared by Gary senior welfare officers who worked for the commission.
Well life went on for years and if every man. And during that period. There was a change of ministers.
And one of Terri Sharon became minister and the chairman invited him down for afternoon tea and Terry came down
and we thought he was great and he was a minister. Very good in fact and he said to me. Now listen face to.
I want you to be a commission. Oh I said that's the last thing I want. But I have never known anyone to say that.
There was a very high sitting fee and you know it was like.
And Terry look how do you think about all I now it's like when a whole lot of poor people come up
and I can sift through the applications and say I think this one is that one. But what I know are bad buildings and.
You just commission. And you do what you believe to be right.
And I didn't last very long as a commissioner it just wasn't my cup of tea.
You were sociate it with a hassling commission went to quite a long time quite a long time so I went back
and I sat on the board that allocated the house.
But during that time they were both two places that were considered to be.
And not only important but prestige as you say and we got very good treatment and the chairman.
The chairman of the commission was like by the name. Kelly. Very well known in labor. It always seemed that he was.
And he spoke to me to the hilt and he would drive to inspect and put me
and my colleague Helen Helen House Rogers on a plane to meet the back. And we would come back.
Inspecting all the houses. And you know we derive. And housing estate and I want to feel.
Really in to tell us oh are you staying overnight here tonight. It was great. It really was. But it did help me.
To understand. The thinking people who are working. Most of us could comfortably came from work. That were narrow.
That was many were so small minded nothing existed that est nothing.
Yet that's exactly when I was having a meal one day. Cup of tea. And you know if I thought yes for.
The working class people the most racist. Because they don't want their little world.
And I found the young white people the most tolerant. But having had this experience with people living in housing he.
Convinces me. There were times when they truly resented me looking at their house. And Kelly was always aware of the.
Great to him but he was an extremely sensitive person.
And he said to me that it was a great eye opener for me that sitting on the boat to allocate to the very disadvantaged
also had a lot to do with. Women who had been. Women who had suffered. Physical violence. And it's very interesting.
I had a woman absolutely beautiful loved.
Just everything half rainy and rainy and she married this chap who was a Christian.
But he soon dropped that he became a confirmed gambler. And an alcoholic and he used to beat her.
And I discussed it in our look. You should never allow anyone to put their finger on you.
And she said well I want to get out of this it was a beautiful house. At Belmont.
And he kept stealing things out of the house to flog them for gambling but. So. I said Would you leave him. Tomorrow.
So I went over to read for my friend brindle who. Had a truck.
And I said Listen Cade going to leave your mind you came was very nice is oh good i have. I BRING ME truck.
It took the truck. Joe Which was it for.
And she put all her treasures into a lovely chair and she had some beautiful things and.
When the truck was well I can get it because I had found her you know for her. And he said. I'm packing.
She will be back. And she was in the next week. So when I went home to the special committee.
This was what was happening with so many of the women who had been brutally beaten. By the house.
We'd allocated and the next thing he would be there.